-Welcome back, everybody.
We have such a big show
for you tonight.
And you know what?
Today is Thanksgiving.
It's my favorite part of this
holiday is eating the leftovers.
I actually have some
in "The Tonight Show" freezer.
If you guys don't mind,
I'd just like to help myself
really quick.
I'll only take a second.
I'm sorry about this.
[ Dramatic music playing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Freezer Secrets."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Pounding ]
Oh, no!
I'm stuck!
Someone! Someone help!
I'm stuck in the freezer!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
It's no --
[ Laughs ]
Okay. Wait, wait.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-Alright! Alright! Alright!
I'm stuck in the freezer.
-It's no --
It's no use, Jimmy.
-Cher!
What are you doing here?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I was trying
to get away from you!
[ Laughter ]
-Great. Now we're trapped
inside this soundproof freezer.
We're doomed.
-Well, okay,
but since this might be the end,
I have a few secrets
I have to get off of my chest.
-Same.
[ Heartfelt music playing ]
You know when you're updating
your phone
and it says
"Terms and Conditions"?
-Mm-hmm.
-Well, I actually read
all the terms and conditions
before I click "accept."
It takes like three hours,
but I think it's worth it.
-You know my song
if "I Could Turn Back Time"?
-Of course it's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a classic.
-Well, I wrote it
when I found out
I was going to be booked
on your show.
[ Laughter ]
-That song has a new meaning
to me.
I have three confessions.
I shot JR.
I let the dogs out.
And I know where Waldo is.
He's at a Bed Bath & Beyond
in New Jersey.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Alright, I have one.
When I go to a hotel,
I check in under an alias
so that no one knows me.
-Wow.
What name do you use?
-Jimmy Fallon.
-That's interesting.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Know no one bothers you?
-No.
-No. They don't
even pay any attention to me.
-[ Laughs ]
My family thinks I cook
the Thanksgiving turkey
every year, but I don't.
I just 3D print it.
[ Laughter ]
-I've won an Oscar,
an Emmy, a Grammy.
I have multiple
platinum records,
and I've sold out stadiums
all over the world.
But I never got to do
the one thing I really,
really wanted to do.
-What is that?
-I wanted to ride
an Oscar Mayer Wienermobile.
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry. I'm so sorry.
-No, it's not a joke. It's sad.
-No. I know, I know, I know.
[ Laughter ]
Let me tell you something
I never told anyone.
I never did my own sketches
on "Saturday Night Live."
-Do you want to hold my hand?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-I never did my own sketches
on "Saturday Night Live."
When I got to showtime, I would
pass out from stage fright.
Will Ferrell and Tracy Morgan
would puppet my body
"Weekend at Bernie's" style.
[ Laughter ]
-It was probably an improvement.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-My name isn't --
Actually, I hate to say this.
My name isn't actually Cher.
-What?
-It's pronounced "sure."
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you for telling me,
"Sure."
I wanna tell you something.
I never learned
how to peel a banana,
so I just eat them whole.
[ Laughter ]
[ Giggles ]
-[ Laughs ] That's sad!
-It is. Yeah.
The joke and the banana.
-Exactly.
-Okay.
♪♪
-Do you have something
you want to tell me?
-I do. Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you for reminding me.
-No, no, no, no. we have time.
-I was overcome by the banana.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
I could show you if there's
any bananas in here.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
You know my song "Believe"?
-Of course. That was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was the first song
to ever use Auto-Tune.
-It's not Auto-Tune.
It's just something
that I can naturally do
with my voice
[tuned] anytime I want.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey! Sure?
Sure's friend?
-Oh, my gosh! Higgins!
We're saved!
What are you guys doing in here?
-No, he's my friend,
and you have to stay here
with your bananas.
-Wait, what?
No, no, I'm not going --
Wait, wait. Hold on, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Tuned ]
Happy Thanksgiving, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This has been
"Freezer Secrets."
Stick around
for more "Tonight Show."